Jason Momoa called out Chris Pratt in an
epic way but guys he's already saying
he's super sorry about it here's what
went down on Tuesday the Aquaman star
proved he really does care about our
oceans when he urged Chris to ditch his
single-use plastic for a reusable water
bottle just hours after Chris posted
this pic of himself at the gym on
Instagram with the bottle in question
lots of celebs chimed in praising
Chris's hot bod in the post including
his wife Catherine Schwarzenegger who
plastered some heart.i emojis in the
comments section I feel good man
her brother Patrick wrote looking ripped
and Sean Hayes said is that a picture of
me oh wait no no it is not me common
mistake I just count my blessings every
day but Jason was hashtag not impressed
he hit up the comment section writing
bro I love you but WTF on the water
bottle no single-use plastic come on
well just a few hours later Jason who is
a big advocate of recyclables and has
his own brand of still alkaline spring
water packaged in aluminum cans issued
an apology to Chris sharing this pic of
himself with Chris and the two kids he
shares with his wife lisa bonet on
instagram alongside the caption bro you
know my children and I are madly in love
with you and I love everything you do
I'm sorry this was received so badly
today I didn't mean for that to happen
but Jason didn't stop there
he went on explaining why he felt the
need to speak out quote I'm just very
passionate about this single use plastic
epidemic the plastic water bottles have
to stop I hope you make a reusable water
bottle for Amazon so we all can purchase
and if that weren't enough he added your
and inspiration to many I'm one of them
oh and he made sure to tag Chris in the
post just to make sure his message was
sieved a 2012 last time I shaved
goodbye Drogo fire decree but this isn't
the first time jason has talked about
his passion for the cause I just want to
do this to bring awareness the plastics
are killing our planet and I think I
have a solution I don't want to [ __ ]
about it there's only one thing you can
really help our planet and save our
planet
as long as we recycle that's aluminium
back in April Jason shaved his famous
beard for the first time in 12 years to
raise awareness about how harmful
plastic is please please
there's a change coming it's aluminum
you gotta get rid of these plastic water
bottles Aquaman's trying to do the best
I can my kids for your kids the world
gonna be really boring
love you guys just when we thought Jason
couldn't be any hotter gotta love a man
who loves mama nature of course you can
count on et to bring you all the updates
about Jason and Chris so make sure to
keep it locked right here until next
time I'm Hallie Stevens
see you soon
[Music]